Then she has,
she gets pregnant and she has twins.
And this is an interesting thing.
The twins fight inside her.
She can tell that they're
not getting along.
And this is an echo,
right?
It's an echo of Cain and Abel and there's
a mythological motif that the unions
have called the hostile brothers,
the hostile brothers.
And you see them all the time.
Batman and the joker are hostile brothers
and Thor and Loki or hostile brothers
and I,
it's an unbelievably common motif and uh,
you know,
the ultimate hostile
brothers or Christ and Satan.
So that's the,
that's the archetipal representation
of the hostile brothers,
right?
The ultimate good and the ultimate evil.
And so,
and so it's an echo of
the Cain and Abel story,
although it's a little more complex,
I would say from a literary point of
view because it isn't obvious which of
these brothers,
his cane and which of them is able,
they have parts of both in each of them.
So Esau,
who turns out to be one of the brothers
and Jacob move turns out to be the
other,
both have their admiral bull
qualities and their faults.
Anyways,
I'm Esau comes is born first,
but Jacob hasn't by the heel.
And so there was a fight within the
womb to see who would emerge first.
Now that's relevant because the
firstborn had a special status,
while has a special status
in many communities,
especially agricultural communities.
And there's a reason all these
people were more hurts people.
But if you divide your property
equally among all your children,
then he'd like three generations.
Everybody has one goat and
everybody starves to death,
you know?
Or the same thing happens with lands.
So one of the ways that that traditional
communities solve that as they just
give them almost everything to the first
born and then the everyone else knows,
well,
you go out and do whatever you can
and it's kind of arbitrary and unfair,
but you know,
at least it's predictably arbitrary
and unfair instead of doom over four
generations,
you know?
So it actually mattered to be the first
born and God generally favors the first
born.
And then you might think,
well,
what is it about being born first?
It's so relevant,
uh,
apart from the,
the cultural practice of,
of a board.
Generous inheritance.
And I would say,
well,
the first born is something like the
model for the leader of the family,
right?
Because the first born child should be,
if there's a number of siblings,
a should take care of the
siblings at least to some degree,
but also should be a role model for them.
So it's like a natural
position of leadership,
but there's a cycle.
There's a cycle psychologize of the
idea of the firstborn in these stories
because God often passes over the first
born in favor of a later born child.
Um,
he seems to do that on the
basis of moral character,
essentially.
And so there's this idea that,
well,
there's a natural proclivity
towards leadership.
That's just a biological fact that
would be associated being a first born.
But there's an element of character,
a logical development
that transcends that.
And so that you,
it's more important to be
spiritually a firstborn,
let's say,
than to be biologically a first born.
And God recognizes that continually in
these stories and inverts the natural
order and favors a later board who's,
who's done more work with regards
to characterological development.